from The Daily Mail
germaphobe Howard Stern leaves his
apocalypse bunker for the first time in
two years for A-list dinner with
Jennifer Aniston Jimmy Kimmel and Jon
Hamm and admits he's been afraid of
catching coven how many times that's
just it that's just a wow moment his
immune system has just got to be shot he
hasn't seen a gerb in two years yeah
he's gonna get real sick he's going to
get really really sick it's not going to
be covet either whatever it's going to
be exactly he's completely he's gonna
get everything it's going to be like Mr
Burns you Remember The Simpsons and the
germs through the door he probably
bought a whole jug of like uh
antiseptic alcohol sanitizer which again
that kills your immune system too kills
your immune system and kills the good
bacteria as well as the bad bacteria and
you need you know a combination of good
bacteria doesn't have a healthy gut the
radio host admitted on Monday the outing
was emotionally exhausting and it was
the first time in two years I ventured
out of the house who still listens to
this guy you are listening to someone
who is not well dude needs broke deep
deep therapy he's saying it was
emotionally exhausting for the first
time in two years bro isolated himself
for two years do not take advice from
this man I don't know I don't know who
is it's still following this guy's
politics this guy is out of his mind
yeah and but he is in a 20 million
dollar home so it couldn't have been too
bad too too
I'm sure I know I'm not sure I'm sure
he's got a a pinball machine a hot tub
he's got an infinity pool and all that
great stuff that's not the point the
point is the dude is agoraphobic like
this is not the kind of person that you
should be listening to consistently
does anybody listen to this guy
consistently yeah he's got like tens of
millions of listeners on on Sirius or
whatever he's still on he imprisoned
himself in his own mind which is
absolutely terrifying because he was a
perfect byproduct of what the corporate
media wanted the average citizen to be
and as we were talking you know you need
good bacteria and bad bacteria but but
when you when you lack good bacteria in
your gut this is correlated with a lot
of people having very negative mental
health so I think there's a correlation
with him being overly protective using
too much hand sanitizers using too much
stuff not going outside not being in
nature not feeling the dirt not getting
any sun not getting any vitamin D that
correlated with his mental decline that
has led to a situation where he
literally imprisons himself and doesn't
go outside for two years check it check
us out he said quote I said to my wife I
don't want to go I'm in a panic I don't
want to get covered yeah anxiety if you
want to leave now yeah it's agoraphobia
it's not germophobia it's agoraphobia
maybe it was a trump derangement
syndrome May if Trump would have said
yeah you guys should all stay in your
house he would have freaked out and he
would have been partying every night
that's a good point man that's crazy
Stern however was reportedly maskless
the dinner party according to a diner
who had snapped the photo how big was
there without even a mask on the outside
the large table Stern told the
restaurant staff it was his first night
out since the start of the pandemic yo
that's
wearing a mask and it's his first time
out or was he well he probably realizes
you know like hey this doesn't work
either
this is pointless after looking at the
data after after being so long but it's
going somewhere to eat too like yeah
yeah I mean we know we know the rules of
restaurants right like you take the mask
off and when you're sitting down
you know what would be really ironic is
that if he gets covered now and then
he's like I was like I got it I went out
I gotta go back in for two more I mean
he's got to be shots boosters he's got
to have it all yes which again a lot of
data is coming out highlighting some
interesting findings
highlight that he probably will be
getting sick especially if he well just
yeah whatever he's gonna get something
absolutely you can't lock yourself up
for two years whether it's the flu yeah
whether it's whether it's the cold
whatever it is it's going to hit him
it's going to hit him hard that's why
periodically I go outside and eat steak
right off the ground just to make sure
them is strong
that's one way of doing it just just
make sure no animal poops in there but
yeah grounding being in the sun being in
nature uh you know just being exposed to
to other germs and bacteria gives you a
good immune system this is why a lot of
people
some people actually have supplements
and the supplements are from dirt
there's actually medications from dirt
that are also very controversial that we
can all talk about hold on no you're
supposed to eat dirt but let me let me
clarify we used to get a lot of
nutrients because we would pull the
vegetables out of the ground or off
branches and they have like not like
thick dirt you're eating dirt but
there's like dust and dirt still on the
plant and you do you eat it we started
cleaning all that stuff off and I was
reading about how that lowered the
amount of B vitamins we were getting not
just that but because of mono cropping
because of simply just growing corn and
soy and allowing Monsanto to control the
entire agriculture industry along with
other big corporate Giants we have
destroyed nutrition from our vegetables
and fruits a lot of the fruits lot of
the vegetables don't contain the same
amount of macronutrients as they
previously did before decades ago and
therefore our food is slowly and surely
being wilted away to absolutely be mush
that is meaningless without any kind of
sustenance for you as a human being so
do I have to buy 10 tomatoes and eat
them instead of five well yeah yeah do I
eat double the the salad now or what do
I do well you've got to be careful with
the glycopate inside of there I went to
uh Stonewall Jackson's Shenandoah
compound because it's in um it's in
Winchester I think it was like you use
it for a few months while he was playing
the defense of the Shenandoah during the
Civil War and in the kitchen they had a
a a a musket from like 1820 up on the
wall and they said what they would do is
when they're making dinner they would
have the door open and if they saw a
critter outside I'd grab the musket and
just shoot it and then take it and throw
it in the stew like fresh just like that
it's kind of a crazy thought eating
squirrel groundhog rabbit or Badger or
whatever they happen to see but also the
crazy thought of something so fresh
taken right from the yard Bang there you
go here's dinner right from the other
crazy thing was they had a wind they
called winter Pantry right above the
kitchen they just took meat and hung it
up they didn't refrigerate it or
anything you know so I we I was I was at
a steakhouse and they had the the dry
aging steaks just sitting out and it was
like gotta be it's like sits out for a
month it's kind of a crazy thought
people would just throw the meat in a
room and hang it back there you go put
some salt on it and kind of store it
that way I don't think they even did
that yeah I think when they were
transporting and stuff they would they
would smoke it and then just leave it up
there I guess
yeah I mean my family still does that in
Poland every time I go to Poland they're
like oh yeah you know we're just smoking
the meat just having a bunch of jokes
there
so I guess he had people
um just delivering ubereats and stuff to
his house or family or I don't know if
he had Uber Eats coming in or or yeah I
guess they could drop it on the doorstep
or something
he has like what are those rooms called
where it's like one door opens and then
you put the food and then it closes the
contamination room yeah like it sprays
it then he opens it up and takes it out
I wouldn't be surprised if that's
exactly
get Lysol raise it everywhere he's
wealthy enough he'd probably want to do
uh I wouldn't be surprised if you got
like special order Farm food that was
harvested by like his select people
because the thing about fast food is
like you don't know what they're doing
when they prepare it I remember that
viral video where a dude was at Taco
Bell I think it was Taco Bell and he
stood in the lattice or something like
that do you guys remember that oh yeah
it was Burger King or something yeah
yeah he was like standing in it there's
a bunch of videos where people do that
where they're like screwing with the
food and then they were posting it
online you never know man for all we
know you know Howard Stern orders uh
what's that ghost grocery delivery
service you can order I don't know
whatever instacart is that it is he
orders ice cream and he gets the one ice
cream that girl licked and put back oh
so he think you think you're safe Howard
Stern you're getting the germs in your
food when you order it I mean did he
keep his Maids I mean I assume he's got
a 20 million dollar mansion He had made
yeah you guys must stay yeah he probably
was like we're all in her house arrest
now it would have worked for me you got
to stay here no leaving
yo what happened to people like this
dude used to be an edgelord and now he's
just like a terrified panic attack
agoraphobe I mean really just think
about it though if everybody did what he
did
or you want to have people producing
anything you want to have food I mean I
guess unless he started I'm not worried
about my own thing in his yard but we
got we got a bunch of Critters and deer
all over the place and I'm not gonna
pretend like you know we we would be
able to survive off the land or anything
like that but I'm confident that um
after some hardship if everything were
to collapse we'd be all right out here
we'd figure it out and we would we would
find a way people in cities and people
like him they would just melt they would
be sitting it would just like slowly
become one with his chair and just like
it stuck to it and be like and then
within a couple weeks he'd be gone he
also became very angry he uh criticized
very heavily Joe Rogan Aaron Rodgers he
even uh Howard Stern specifically said
that if if you're unvaccinated you
should be denied treatment out of out of
hospitals hospitals should be quote
closed to individuals who are not
vaccinated so this is a man who wants to
see other people suffer who wants to see
other people die as of course he's taken
for granted his lifestyle that of course
the average poor person can afford the
an average person can't hide in a 20
million dollar mansion and not be able
to to work or or do hard labor or blue
collar work so for him to go out and say
this uh on on the heels of his paranoia
is just mind-boggling I remember you had
people advocating on the news on CNN uh
doctors advocating for
um not allowing you to fly state to
state because that's a federal issue now
uh unless you're vaccinated I was like
oh [ __ ] but we're all doing this
together we're all in this together but
if you have a private jet not a big deal
you can you can still go wherever you
want thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there